Popular opinion is that you should get eight hours
of sleep a night, but it might not actually be the
number of hours you sleep, but the quality
of your sleep that matters.
Scientists aren’t totally sure why we evolved
to sleep.
When we sleep we’re unconscious to the world
leaving us vulnerable to predators, but every
species that has been studied in detail sleeps,
so there’s something beneficial to it!
Not sleeping well isn’t just annoying, it’s
linked to poor overall health, lack of focus,
memory loss, and Alzheimer’s disease.
We’ve talked about sleep a lot.
Broadly speaking, there are two kinds of sleep,
non-rapid eye movement (NREM) and rapid eye
movement (REM) sleep.
Together they encompass the stages of sleep
that are vital for feeling rested in the morning.
If sleep is cut short we don’t go through
all these phases.
This can lead to anxiety, depression, fatigue,
physical pain, and sleep disorders ranging
from insomnia to hypersomnia, which is sleeping
too much.
Bad sleep can even stop us from forming memories.
A new study looked at dendrites, branching
outgrowths from neurons that carry electrical
signals from synapses to the cell body.
Activity in dendrites increases during sleep.
That increase is linked to short and repetitive
brain waves called spindles.
These spindles peak at the beginning and end
of a non-REM sleep cycle, the latter-end is
marked by slow wave activity in the brain.
During that peaking you’re in a deep-sleep
phase.
And without it, your memories suffer.
So it’s that deep-sleep phase right before
REM sleep that we really need.
The slow waves are associated with the most
prominent brain activity during sleep.
They help transfer memories from the hippocampus
to the prefrontal cortex where they are consolidated
and stored.
These slow waves are also linked to attention
in wakeful hours, heart health, metabolic
regulation, and overall cognition.
By the way, missing out on that deep sleep
can be as simple as having anxiety.
When we’re stressed, our bodies are primed
to respond to situations by waking up.
When you’re stressed the amygdala’s “fight
or flight” response doesn’t totally shut
down.
This means, you can’t enter that deep sleep
restorative phase!
Without this restorative sleep, we don’t
restore our brain to a baseline condition.
And over the years this adds up.
The link between poor sleep and Alzheimer’s
isn’t from a few bad nights, it’s from
YEARS of poor sleep that doesn’t allow the
brain to properly repair itself.
So what can you do?
A lot of research points to sleep hygiene
as a simple place to start.
The same way you shower to clean your body
you want to clean your sleeping space.
Establishing healthy sleep habits like avoiding
caffeine in the afternoon, not napping late
in the day, keeping screens out of the bedroom,
and exposing yourself to light patterns that
mimic your circadian rhythm.
Of course, the stresses that are keeping your
brain from fully relaxing are less simple
to fix, but worth working on it if means healthy
sleep for a healthy life.
If you like this video be sure to subscribe
for more Seeker, we’ve got a so many videos
on sleep!
Click here to watch.
You’ll sleep better at night.
And speakin of…
Did you know, some birds can sleep while flying
by keeping part of their brain awake!
I wish I could do that.